welcome to the foundation series for
email marketing
i'm matt bailey president of site logic
and faculty chair market motive for
email marketing
in this introduction course i want to
challenge you with your thinking about
email do you really know it
a lot of people assume that they know
email and it's become a very boring
subject it's typically how i get all my
spam is from email has what a lot of
people say
but the problem is you don't know what's
been happening in the email industry
over the past few years
email has become one of the most
powerful ways of reaching new customers
retaining old customers and building a
lifetime customer that will continue to
be a part of your business
how has email been transformed from this
once spam filled marketing method to
becoming one of the most powerful
marketing methods now
in your marketing arsenal
the first thing is most people start
their day not only with that first cup
of coffee but going through their email
they're looking to see all the messages
that they've received deleting reading
keeping up on the news mostly that's
through email
but also the proliferation of mobile
devices has now increased the
accessibility to email
people have their email with them all
the time and now one out of every two
email opens is on a mobile device
customers actually prefer to receive
marketing messages via email rather than
any other channel
they want to control that
and they have the time to deal with it
when they can
and so email is the preferred method of
receiving those messages and it also
contributes to a higher lifetime value
in getting customers
and getting new customers to your
business
one study by the direct marketing
association
shows that for every dollar that was
spent in email marketing companies
received forty dollars in revenue
the power of email marketing is that it
creates loyalty among your customers and
your customers respond to that because
they get to know you
it's a way to educate
to expand and to grow customers into
knowing more about your company which
results in a higher lifetime value
than most other marketing channels email
creates value to the company
now the problem with email is that it
always hasn't been so sexy in creating
value to the company
marketers when they got a hold of email
started asking themselves what's
possible
rather than asking should we do this and
as a result when you ask people what the
problem with email is
they'll tell you i get too much it's not
relevant it's not important it's i'm
getting email from people i don't even
know
and so because of that email suffered a
reputation problem
there were things that we were receiving
that we didn't know how to control
lists that we got on that we don't know
how we got on those lists and ultimately
the messages were just spammy and not
even targeted
and so this created almost a split
personality now that emails the primary
source of spam that i receive but it's
also the primary messaging medium from a
lot of companies that i do want those
messages
and so email has had a bit of a comeback
because of the technology because of
mobile marketing and because of
companies using it in a way that's
smarter and more targeted in creating a
conversation with the customer